cards against humanity' is a famous game
for being offensive so if you're easily
offended then don't watch this video
someday but I have kids I want to share
with them the joys of sucking the
president's dick some damn kids often to
share the joys of chicken and waffles
well that's pretty obvious
in cards against humanity each round a
black card is presented on this black
card it says an unfinished sentence your
job is to complete the sentence with
your white cards the funniest sentence
wins what's there a ton of in heaven
what serotonin sexual tension
Gloria his glory glory and the cards are
chicks big blank nice blowing a child's
head over the rocket lesson nice chicks
the smallest wise dick 9 nice oh this
one kinda relates to me so I gotta get a
pic the next episode spongebob gets
introduced to blink done spongebob gets
reduced to Scientology budget Rob gets
introduced to 72 virgins I like to see
the Scientology episode oh [ __ ]
I'm trying not to listen to you guys
yeah Vegeta what does the scouter say
come day
I never thought Blanc would be so
enjoyable be good gentlemen you could be
so good with this they're like balancing
each other out what's wrong with Mecca
Hitler okay congratulations
expecting a burp involving a Jew lations
hey now this is a sweet Mexican flat
tire
welcome to my secret lair on blake
hormone injections my secret base is the
new fad diet is all about making people
do mm-hmm and eat mm-hmm people do eight
and the new fad diet is all about making
people do the three-fifths compromise
eat a middle-aged man on road make a
back into eighths my favorite people die
when they are just because it matches
the sentence people die when they are
angry naked people people die when they
are riding off into the I make sense
that I know this is Felix's I don't give
points there are guilty pleasures and
then there's what's the next big sensual
attraction fancy pants pants pants are
you [ __ ] kidding me
actually dude I don't know yours is oh
my god your own cultural little [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] I would have won that
because you didn't know what ouch wits
was you [ __ ] jeah
gimon digivolve into mine this oh my god
ditch my digivolve to
Digimon Digimon - Vicky's God I thought
it was like you know the intro of this
Digimon digital monsters Digimon and
Stan's a stance
someday when I have kids I want to share
with them the joys of Blink someday I
want to share with them the joys of
sucking the president's deep suddenly
when I am kids Austin to share the joys
of chicken and waffles that's pretty
obvious
sucking the presentation there are
whisperings that the Vatican has a
secret room devoted to the Vatican is a
secret room devoted to jerking off into
a pool of okay that one is better I got
my power card out if you try out if you
try creeping Portia saw out if you try
creepy it's better I like a blow-dryer
she's cold for a long time I would
totally go gay for make her feel a
deeper Justin Bieber
yeah I don't know okay I'll admit it I
would totally go gay for our Justin
Bieber come on Ken what the [ __ ] what
what never fails to liven up the party
this is not a good round what never
fails to liven up the party this is
sexual appetites or Ian would win damn
it I want one more I want to win one for
my next trick I will pull out German
Dutch and porn out of homeless people
for my next trick I will pull geese out
of Kenna pots
I mean I gotta I gotta get the porn
either yeah boy would you rather suck
Blake or get [ __ ] ba-bling uh
glad you guys are ganging up on me like
this you won't let me win the last one
in Jack's like I wanna be would you
rather suck horns and hooves are you
addicted is aim sex ice down yeah Koko
can really yeah there you go
how do you out even suck Morgan
Freeman's voice honestly I'd rather be
dick by him these are great step 1
blank step 2 blank step 3 profit ok step
1 sniffing glue step 2 necrophilia step
3 profit step 1 passing a kidney stone
step 2 silence this one Oh
see how you get profit from the other
one this one head might be actually a
good idea cuz got passed a kidney stone
and then be solid man here
how did I lose my virginity that was
fast on that one it all comes out today
hey girl I'm popular on YouTube you want
to get it home
I remember when blank was just getting
started then I remember when a sexually
frustrated Griffon was just getting
started I remember I remember when the
Big Bang was just getting started like
the TV show yeah no not the actual Big
Bang and that was the joke about it you
never get it I did I just made another
joke but you didn't get it oh well
nevermind I will always get you laid
three teams today it's a weird that I
want to rub my face is there weird that
I want to rub my face on blank I mean I
guess we don't rub my face on 72 virgins
or is it weird that I will rub my face
of Lance Armstrong to missing testicle
being a little bit